Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this series, we talk a lot about photorealistic
rendering, which is one of the most exciting
areas in computer graphics research.
Photorealistic rendering means that we put
virtual objects in a scene, assign material
models to them, and then run a light simulation
program to create a beautiful image.
This image depicts how these objects would
look like in reality.
This is particularly useful for the film industry
because we can create highly realistic scenes
and set them up in a way that we couldn't
do in real life.
We can have any possible object we can imagine,
light sources that we wouldn't ever be able
to buy, change the time of the day, or even
the planet we're on.
Practically, we have an infinite budget.
That's amazing!
However, creating such an image takes a long
time, often in the order of hours to days.
Here you can see me render an image and even
if the footage is sped up significantly, you
can see that this is going to take a long,
long time.
Spp means samples per pixel, so this the number
of light rays we compute for every pixel.
The more spp, the cleaner, more converged
image we get.
This technique performs spatiotemporal filtering.
This means that we take a noisy input video
and try to eliminate the noise and try to
guess how the final image would look like.
And it can create almost fully converged images
from extremely noisy inputs.
Well, as you can see, these videos are created
with one sample per pixel, which is as noisy
as it gets.
These images with the one sample per pixel
can be created extremely quickly, in less
than ten milliseconds per image, and this
new denoiser also takes around 10 milliseconds
to reconstruct the final image from the noisy
input.
And yes, you heard it right, this is finally
a real-time result.
This all happens through decoupling the direct
and indirect effect of light sources and denoising
them separately.
In the meantime, the algorithm also tries
to estimate the amount of noise in different
parts of the image to provide more useful
information for the denoising routines.
The fact that the entire pipeline runs on
the graphics card is a great testament to
the simplicity of this algorithm.
Whenever you see the term SVGF, you'll see
the results of the new technique.
So we have these noisy input videos with 1
spp.
And...look at that!
Wow!
This is one of those papers that looks like
magic.
And, no neural networks or learning algorithms
have been used in this work.
Not so long ago, I speculated, or more accurately,
hoped that real-time photorealistic rendering
would be a possibility during my lifetime.
And just a few years later, this paper appears.
We know that the rate of progress in computer
graphics research is just staggering, but
this is, this is too much to handle.
Super excited to see where the artists will
take this, and of course, I'll be here to
show you the coolest followup works.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!